uh not playing final fantasy like an
idiot for [ __ ] sake joe for [ __ ]
sake joey i i called you out from the
game okay okay okay like i remember so
we record the episode where joey's like
gone don't play final fantasy 14. i
think it was like four weeks ago yeah
yeah and i'm like i'm like okay joey
you're a good mate i will trust you uh
and then and then what happens i uh get
i get a condition in which i need to
stay in the house every day for about
two weeks straight okay um and i have
nothing to do because i'm not well
enough to work so what i do first i i
complete 13 sentinels uh which is uh oh
you finished it i i finished it and then
uh it was a good it was as [ __ ]
insane as you said it was good and then
i sit there twiddling my thumbs going oh
what now what do i
what do i do now and then i look at the
date and i look at twitter and uh final
fantasy 14 comes back on back on sale to
the public and i'm just like and i'm
just like i don't like either this is a
sign from god or the devil either one
definitely the devil either one it's a
sign the only way to get you guys to do
anything is be like don't do this don't
don't don't don't watch this don't play
this game you don't like it was that the
problem was that i was i was being too
negative i had to do the opposite i
didn't watch arcane this week right
just saying that's it
that's it that's all i'm saying
that's so funny i didn't either yeah
that's crazy right yeah [ __ ] couldn't be
me
yeah i mean talking about addiction joey
i i see
i see i mean you you recently gone into
a new gacha game as well i did yeah we
mentioned it very briefly in the last
episode yeah yeah it's just like the
week where we just what am i going to
start heroin this week as well
i mean
alex's anonymous everything just goes
wrong with this i mean you've recently
just been addicted to a torturing
yourself
i want to be done with it i'm trying to
finish oh you're definitely addicted i'm
not i'm not i'm not i don't like hurting
myself you're like a [ __ ] massive
well you you you don't like hurting
yourself you say after like your tenth
jumping stream it's like then you're
getting it again and then getting over
it and then the pogo stick or i can't
what's up
pogo stuck that's it well first of all
i want to clarify i don't enjoy
referring myself but
i enjoy a challenge
right sometimes challenging is that not
just mentally
challenges require us to go through some
uncomfortable feelings and challenges i
get that you know challenges
no i i get that sentiment but i think
what makes a challenge you know
satisfying is when you do it
every now and then yeah you know not
every stream well you know what you know
what i i this like revelation where i
was sitting there and i was like
you know
nobody bats an eye if you spend 1 000
hours playing at fps the moment you put
10 hours into a shitty jumping game
everyone's like you've got a problem you
know what's up with that well i still
think putting a thousand hours into an
fps yeah i mean
you don't know you're not a gamer a
thousand hours into an fps is not over
how long i don't know like a month
okay no that is that is a problem that
is there is there even a thousand hours
in a month
[Music]
it would be just under i think because
that would be a slight that would be a
different problem entirely if there
wasn't no there is not yeah there is
there is what am i saying how many hours
in a month 720 hours yeah okay okay yeah
so this man is like in the hyperbolic
time chamber
youtube at one point five times
yes
so i i feel like fps i can get it
because at least there's a bit more
variety than literally pressing a button
and pointing in the direction and uh
doing that for 10 hours straight i've
never had like my wrists hurt before
from gaming but during the space bar
games that that hurts my wrist
like a dementia stream i'm just going
around and doing the same thing over and
over again yeah not making any progress
and but when i do beat it i i've touched
that's what i'm saying it's good content
to watch not to do well it's a great
youtube highlight yeah because then it's
done but when you're in the middle of it
you're like i don't know if i can do
this i'm gonna have a mental breakdown
right i don't know if this can be done
markiplier did like seven youtube parts
and just gave up yeah i mean i mean like
soul crushing that is i mean like it's
good content in the same way that you
know mr b saying pewdiepie a million
times yeah is good content you know but
you know it's not exactly what i'd call
fun and it's definitely uh it's it's
definitely suffering that's not a j i
can you know bring back yeah so i you
know i'd be be all the jumping dlc i'm
probably gonna do the the other one at
some point i might have done it by the
time this comes out i don't know who
knows but um
i i finished playing it and i was like
oh my god thank god the challenge is
over i can finally rest yeah and i
played pokemon arceus
and like it was kind of difficult
but at no point did i ever think i can't
do this like yeah of course it's a
pokemon game and i missed that i missed
that moment where i was like i don't
know if i can do this like this is so
difficult i need this see that's why
you're a gamer and i'm not because the
moment i see a part of the game where
i'm like i can't do this i'm like guess
i'll die and i just don't do it but like
when i know someone else has done
something i'm like well i can do it then
why don't you play sifu then what's that
oh
yeah seafood it's it's like a new game
that just came out which is kind of like
based on you know old old-school martial
arts films and i've heard it's like
pretty damn hard and it's pretty damn
challenging uh it's like got i mean i i
haven't played it yet but i've seen
other streamers and other people talk
about it and uh i mean i don't want to
use like the dark souls analogy because
everyone uses the [ __ ] dark souls
analogy like you know difficulty didn't
exist before dark souls but i have heard
that it is a challenging game to get
through what happens
i feel like dark souls is like nothing
compared to these these rage games right
but what i don't understand is okay you
say you want to go for a challenge ride
yeah you don't want to learn how to
speed run
so speed running is a different thing
for me in thailand i don't think so i
think i think it's exactly i think speed
running is closer to the [ __ ] you're
doing with jump king and pogo stock than
it is to do with so challenging you know
like just different mechanically
mechanical challenging games
here's where this is where i think speed
running for me is like something that i
i mean i've enjoyed it i've done it in
the past i've used speedrun like cop
head
back when they had an exploit in the
game that they removed and then it's
like not really fun to do because it
takes a lot longer now yeah
um yeah so i used to enjoy doing it but
i found that the point was is like okay
let's say you get to a certain point
yeah you get to a really good time and
you start shaving off like micro seconds
right yeah if you're a streamer
and you know you want to stream content
it becomes really difficult to to keep
saying like this is content over and
over again because i'm not a speed
speedrunner i'm trying to make content
right right and so
like if you if i'm trying to make like a
youtube channel i'm trying to make
highlights i can't be like jumping
speedrun highlights part 17 right it
just doesn't work like yeah right i mean
i i've also
with with like saying my pogo stuck or
jump king right when if i'm not speed
running i tried speedrunning jump king i
got pretty good time i got 12 minutes i
think i can do better but again i'd have
to grind it a bunch and it's not that
entertaining but having a hard goal
that is like you have done it at this
point you're done you can stop that's
way more satisfying i think as a viewer
to watch but also as a content creator
it's a lot better for like a narrative
in a video to have like i mean i i think
it's pretty simple to turn speed running
into content you just can you just set
yourself a hard
target a hard number that you get on
like like when i say you should be doing
speed running content i don't mean like
you should be going for a [ __ ] world
record or anything but like you know
like maybe setting your goal to be like
all right if the world record is like 10
minutes in this game yeah then you know
my goal is to get a pb of 15 minutes
that's right well then that that tends
and yeah you could do that i mean like
ludwig did it with like some of the the
games like like can you beat all of jump
king in an hour yeah yeah three all
three maps yeah that's interesting
that's way more appealing to me than
trying to grind and get the best time
yeah very impressive with the people who
can do it
i'm just not consistent enough i mean
it's [ __ ] hard this like these i
don't know man you've been pretty
[ __ ] consistent with all these like
hard hats yeah yeah i mean it you i
think you're like one step away you seem
to have found a niche of just yeah i
will just do this one repetitive thing
that is this one mechanic in the game
and do it for 10 hours and i'm just like
sounds exactly like what a speed runner
because you know it's it's uh one of
those things i keep saying that when i
want to buy time like one of those
things it's one of those things one more
you basically can
you need perseverance to like an extreme
level for a lot of these games
and i feel that
um most people would just think this is
stupid
and i'm just like
i can see like the micro improvements
right i feel the like tiny tiny
improvements every time i feel like this
is pure copium right now no it's not
okay okay okay no no you get better okay
okay because like i get that for like
say a mechanically intensive game like
sifu you know like dark souls you would
not be feeling this satisfied if you
weren't streaming this game no i would
never do it yeah
exactly right because it it isn't as
satisfying like like you're finding like
the
micro
like the micro things that you find fun
about this game to try and cope with how
much of of like how much of a [ __ ] time
how much [ __ ] time you're having while
doing it but at least people are
watching you do it you know
the chat is the silver lining yeah but
like okay so like jump king i initially
i thought i thought that it was dumb i
thought it was stupid i thought it was
unfair yeah
after playing it i think it's like
amazing i feel like it's like incred i'm
not kidding it's an amazing game would
you have said that though if you hadn't
beaten it no
absolutely not right i understand if you
play it and you think it's unfair i
understand that but when you play those
games more and especially like okay pogo
stack is not it's
awful awful game not
you said that about jumping like
literally two two three weeks ago right
jump screen was good this is gonna be
polio's thing's
and he's like best game ever made
amazing
jump king amazing has the bang of
visuals absolutely amazing soundtrack
and i do agree i do like the aesthetics
of jumping it's like a it's a package
you know yeah well i will hold my uh
yeah
i will reserve my opinions because uh by
the time this episode comes out me and
joey will probably have already done our
jump king race
you gonna go for it yeah i mean if we
can sure but i think i mean probably not
on that race but personally yeah yeah if
i start something i'm going to finish it
yeah like if like i think this race is
going to be the reason why i came up
with the race idea is because uh you
know i like myself uh enough to not
torture myself on stream for
entertainment so i was like so he
dragged me
he dragged me i'm like i need someone
else to feel this pain he was literally
on camera yeah you could you could
rewind back
jumping sounds fun go on do you want to
do jump kicks you want to do you haven't
played oh what a coincidence me neither
but uh i think like i mean we've
probably already done it by the time
this episode is coming yeah but like as
of right now i think it's like we're
giving ourselves like maybe
four hours
uh just because god and i are incapable
of streaming for more than four hours in
any game i think 10 to 15 hours is a
good range of how long it might take you
right all right so that race we probably
won't be beat it but i think afterwards
once we get the idea then we'll probably
like individually do it and then try and
beat it it's weird because like games
like that they like trick you
into thinking that the only progress
that matters is how far you've gotten
where it's like
in games like jumping and stuff like
that you're gonna have to restart so
many times so it's not about how far you
can get it's how many times can you do
all of the jumps to the point where you
felt perfect yeah like can you do that
more consistently it kind of sounds like
speedrunning kind of yeah yeah
i mean i
at least mean it
king you get a mental break you know you
can stop for a moment and you can kind
of like okay right pogo stuck it doesn't
stop the pogo doesn't stop moving it's
just awful so like speed running yeah
yeah
[Laughter]
i mean the more i think about it the
more i think about it poker stock is
just a speed running yeah it's it's a
speed running simulator yeah
try it try it it's one of those games
that looks a lot easier than it is for
sure i mean i've done like been at 40s
getting over it that's easy that's not
man like coop and stuff like that i'm
just like even then i was just like i
thought getting over it was hard after
playing these games getting over it is
like medium not even like hard yeah i
mean i be getting over it in three hours
my first time
so
well i feel like you started with jump
king and then
like i guess you downgraded to getting
over it you get the mindset it's not
about how good you are at the games it's
about getting the mindset to improve the
games
i feel like i feel like i could i just
i'll just go into like zen mode you need
zero zero range oh yeah you can't you
can't beat a game like that while
[ __ ] being like
i did
i was furious
it's so hyped yeah
if you ever get to the top of the
castles yeah like the soundtracks are
like oh yeah i can imagine it